vamos a hacer un problema de
calentamiento de razones para que
después podamos resolver otros más
difíciles supongamos que tenemos que 13
entre 6 la razón 13 entre 6 es igual a
la razón 5 entre x y que queremos
determinar el valor de x bueno aquí la x
está en el denominador y eso no nos
gusta porque la hace difícil algebraica
mente así que vamos a hacer que quede en
el numerador multiplicando a ambos lados
de la igualdad por x multiplicamos por x
aquí multiplicamos por x acá de este
lado esta x se cancela con esta x y nos
queda que 13 entre 6 por x 13 entre 6
por x es igual a 5 a 5 sale bueno
después de esto podemos multiplicar por
el inverso de 13 sextos en ambos lados
de la igualdad es decir multiplicamos
por 6 entre 13 por 6 entre 13 y con esto
vamos a despejar x porque de este lado
estos términos se cancelan justo eso era
el punto de multiplicar por el inverso y
de este lado nos queda 6 por 5 que es 30
entre 3 de esta forma
es igual a 30 a 30 entre 3 muy bien
bueno puede ser que algunas veces veas
que unas personas hagan algo que se
llama multiplicar cruzado eso qué quiere
decir
quiere decir multiplicar el numerador de
este lado por el denominador de este
lado e igualarlo al numerador de este
lado multiplicado por el denominador de
este lado vamos a hacerlo para que veas
a lo que me refiero o sea voy a volver a
copiar el problema decía que 13 entre 6
es igual a 5 entre x entonces estas
personas dicen hay que multiplicar 13
por x lo ponemos de un lado y eso es
igual a 5 por 6 y lo ponemos del otro y
ya de aquí queda esta igualdad estoy
aquí pues parece magia verdad porque
parece un mecanismo que tenemos que
hacer pero no sabemos por qué porque
funciona y bueno la razón por la cual
funciona es muy sencillo simplemente hay
un paso intermedio que es multiplicar
por ambos denominadores de ambos lados
de la igualdad es decir lo que estamos
haciendo en el fondo es multiplicar aquí
por 6x o sea la multiplicación de estas
6 con esta x y de este lado también por
6x
saleh y qué sucede este 6 se cancela con
este 6 esta x con esta x y justo queda
que 13 x x es igual a 5 x 6 que es igual
a 30 vale y bueno a partir de aquí
podemos despejar x multiplicando por 1
entre 13 o bueno dividiendo entre 13
dividimos entre 13 acá y acá aquí se
cancelan y justo nos queda que x es
igual a 30 entre 13 otra vez muy bien
entonces este fue el problema de
calentamiento vamos a resolver algunos
problemas un poco más difíciles mira
tengo tengo este problema de aquí que
dice lo siguiente dice la montaña más
alta de canadá es el monte el hogar es
de 298 entre 67 la altura del ben nevis
otro monte de hecho dice que es el pico
más alto de escocia bueno vamos a ir
pasando la información vale entonces
dice el monte logan es de 298 entre 67
la altura del ben nevis déjame usar la
letra l para logar y esto es igual a 298
entre 67 la del ben nevis le voy a poner
n para ben nevis vale
bueno luego nos dicen nos dicen el monte
el verde en colorado es el pico más alto
de las montañas rocosas muy interesante
y luego dice el monte el verde el monte
el verde tiene 220 entre 67 la altura
del ben nevis vamos a copiar eso eso se
ve importante
voy a poner para el verde esto es 220
220 entre 67 entre 67 la del ben nevis
que le puse n m y además también nos
dicen que 44 entre 48 a la altura del
montblanc el montblanc que está en
francia vamos a ponerle b para montblanc
entonces el mismo el monte el verde
tiene 44 entre 48 44 entre 48 a la
altura del montblanc lo voy a poner así
y finalmente nos dicen que el montblanc
tiene 4 mil 800 metros de altura vaya al
fin apareció en una medida verdad
entonces nos dice que el mundo nos dicen
que el montblanc tiene cuatro mil
ochocientos
entonces de altura y la pregunta que nos
hacen es cuál es la altura del monte
logra bueno aquí tenemos un montón de
igualdades entonces vamos a ir
encontrando el valor de cada una de las
letras vale como tenemos la ven la ve me
be de burro entonces sería bueno de
terminarla
porque podemos utilizar esta igualdad
entonces déjame sustituir en vez de ver
su valor
entonces reescribiendo esta igualdad nos
queda que él es igual a 44 entre 48 x
4800 4.800 y entonces de aquí nos da el
valor de e
nos queda igual a haber 4800 entre 48 es
100 entonces esto es 100 y luego 100 por
44 es 4.400 entonces nos queda igual a
4.400 metros vale el monte everest mide
4 mil 400 metros bueno ahora esta
información vamos a pasarla para acá
entonces tenemos que 4.400 metros cuatro
mil cuatrocientos metros
igual es igual a 220 entre 67 220 entre
67 por n la de la del ben nevis le voy a
poner por n ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es despejar está n
cómo le hacemos multiplicamos por el
inverso de 220 entre 67 de ambos lados
de la igualdad osea multiplicamos por
aquí por 67 y dividimos entre 220 y
también hacemos lo mismo de este lado
por 67 y dividimos entre 220 muy bien
del lado derecho se cancelan ese era el
punto voy a voltear la igualdad
entonces nos queda que n n la altura del
ben nevis es igual a 67 por 4.400 entre
muy bien vamos a ver qué podemos hacer
aquí y me falta un cero 4400 haber 440
así sin este cero entre 220 es 2 si cabe
justo dos veces 220 en 440 pero además
tenemos este cero entonces haciendo esta
división nos queda 20 va entonces la
altura del ben nevis es igual a 67 por
20 metros y eso podríamos desarrollar
los 2 por 7 es 14 llevamos 12 por 62 es
como mil 340 creo pero bueno lo voy a
dejar expresado así porque al parecer va
a ser útil ese 67 de este lado ahorita
va a saber a lo que me refiero entonces
finalmente sustituimos para obtener la
del monte logan y nos queda que la
altura del monte logan es igual a 298
entre 67 multiplicada por la altura del
betis que es 67 67 por 20 entonces
observa justo aquí está bueno tener el
67 para que se cancele con este de acá y
finalmente nos queda que la altura del
monte logan el monte logan es igual
a ver 298 es casi 302 por 300 de 600
pero pero faltaban 2 para 300 entonces
ahora deben de faltar 4 para 600 o sea 2
por 298 es 596 pero además aquí hay un
cero entonces aquí le tengo que poner
cero entonces la altura del monte
logan es de cinco mil novecientos
sesenta metros muy bien entonces ya
tenemos la altura del monte lo que sale
vamos a resolver un problema de aquí
abajo un problema adicional vale nos
dice lo siguiente dice en una
preparatoria grande se estima que dos de
cada tres estudiantes tienen un celular
y uno de cada cinco tiene un celular que
tiene menos de un año vamos a pasar esta
información lo voy a hacer así le voy a
llamar a equis o más bien voy a llamar x
al número total de estudiantes al número
de estudiantes
estudiantes de la escuela vale
estudiantes
muy bien entonces nos dicen que dos de
cada tres estudiantes tienen un celular
voy a poner en color azul entonces dos
de cada tres tienen un celular esto se
escribe como que dos tercios de x es el
número de estudiantes con celular le voy
a poner estudiantes
estudiantes con celular
celular
vale y además nos dicen que uno de cada
cinco que 1 de cada 5 tiene un celular
que tiene menos de un año entonces un
quinto de x es igual al número de
estudiantes de estudiantes y estudiantes
con celular
el ulular que dice que tiene menos de un
año lo voy a poner menos de un año
muy bien y luego nos dicen de entre los
estudiantes que tienen celular qué
proporción tiene un celular que tiene
más de un año bueno entonces tenemos que
sacar una proporción pero lo que nos
interesa como denominador es los
estudiantes que tienen celular entonces
déjame ponerlos los estudiantes que
tienen celular los voy a poner por acá o
sea la proporción que nos interesa
determinar debe de tener en el
denominador los estudiantes que tienen
celular o sea dos tercios de ellos dos
tercios de equis y de ahí nos preguntan
qué proporción tienen un celular que
tiene más de un año aquí nos dan el
número de estudiantes con celular de
menos de un año entonces tenemos que
ahora encontrar la cantidad de
estudiantes que tienen pues un celular
con más de un año entonces a los que
tienen celular les debemos restar los
que tienen un celular con menos de un
año vale entonces voy a ponerle por aquí
dos tercios de x menos un quinto de x y
justo esto es el número de estudiantes
nada más le voy a poner así esto
con celular
como un celular
de más de un año vale bueno por ahí
están los que tienen exactamente un año
vamos a pensar que están aquí abajo vale
va entonces número de estudiantes con
celular de un año o más entonces vamos a
realizar esta resta para encontrar cuál
es la proporción debemos de pasar estas
fracciones a su denominador común déjame
factorizar la equis le voy a poner acá y
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
pues el denominador común es 15 dos
tercios es lo mismo que 10 entre 15 ya
eso tenemos que restar un quinto y eso
es lo mismo que 3 entre 15 vale y aquí
es 10 menos 13 7 entonces esto es igual
a 77 sobre 15 por equis entonces esto ya
que es el número de estudiantes con
celular de más de un año eso lo tenemos
que poner en el numerador de esta
fracción aquí ponemos 7 entre 15 por
equis vale entonces aquí está el número
de estudiantes con celular de más de un
año y el número de estudiantes con
celular muy bien vamos a ver cuánto nos
da esta proporción la equis se cancela
con la equis eso es bueno porque
queremos un número
y esto nos queda a ver es 7 entre 15 7
entre 15 y tenemos que dividir entre
entre esta fracción lo cual es lo mismo
que multiplicar por su inverso por tres
medios por tres medios muy bien este 3
con este 15 se hace en un quinto aquí se
hace un 1 dividimos entre 3 arriba y
abajo y de esta forma la proporción nos
queda 7 entre 10 vale 7 entre 10 y
entonces 7 entre 10 justo es la
proporción de estudiantes que tienen un
celular con más de un año entre aquellos
que tienen celular y listo con esto
terminamos